So I’ve just told you the difference between
revenue streams and pricing models, but let’s
take a look at an example. So imagine I have
15 sales reps and they cover 27 cities in the
United States, and they are traveling all the
time and they work for me. And by the way,
my product, its material cost is $99 and I
decided I’m going to add $30 gross margin
on top of it, so I sell the product for $129.
So why don’t you think about this for a second
and tell me, which part was the revenue
stream and which part was the pricing tactic.
Are the sales reps in 27 cities the revenue stream,
or are the cost plus $30 the revenue stream.
Was the pricing tactics the sales rep or
was it the cost plus the gross margin.